welcome to the public and we are ready
as an education committee to go ahead
with exacting today first I'd like to
recognize those folks that are sitting
in the committee represent NATO why
don't you introduce yourself
hello I'm Janine notter um I represent
the town of Merrimack
and representative Hall
hi my name is Jennifer Morton I
represent the town of Amherst thank you
and I think we're good on all the way
around elsewhere okay welcome so what we
have today is we have some bills uh on
the docket here I'd like to explain
there are several bills which 382
we have a record that that bill was done
382 came out with a 20-0 recommendation
itl
and representative cordelli is going to
write the
the committee report seeing that he's
the one that made the motion
came out with a octopass
19-0 vote and representative Mel Miller
was the one to make that motion so he
will also write that report
we there was some question regarding the
553 Bill relative to school district
information on Personnel salaries
when there is no record of that bill
being taken so it's on our docket
correctly here
there's absolutely nothing in the file
whereas the other ones do show the roll
call votes in the in the file so we're
good with those other two
so with that I'd like to start right at
the top today with HB 71 repealing at
Department of Education report
on Charter Public School funding
is there a motion
representative forward ought to pass
is there a second
represent Miler makes the second so we
have octopass on repealing a Department
of Education report on Charter Public
School funding made by representative
Ford second by representative mile
representative four to care to speak to
your vote
I think we will promotion to this
extreme that's so I think
you're Mike
literature yes do we um
we're on 71 yep and so according to my
notes uh on
I'm not sure the date we did this
February 1st February 16th we we did
consider an ought to pass that came out
that failed
do we have to reconsider that ought to
pass let me look at it too
what was the date on that February what
um
February 16th see the February 1st of
February 16th I don't know why I've got
both
I think we recently recessed it to 56 oh
to the 16th okay
nice
I see that on the 16th
um HP 71 OTP
dry but that's all been scratched out on
this yeah
right
okay I don't have that on the sheet I
would I would move to
well
not on the prevailing side there's no
Prevail inside
I don't think you need that anymore
but do you want to reconsider the OTP
and then
uh
that motion was made by whom
my cordelli was the original motion
well representative dry is not not here
but represent cordelli is here
and that's the best we can do should we
uh be considered then yeah I I let's
let's go with the most and reconsider
and you make that seeing you made the
second on that in the in person making
emotions not here
so I will move uh reconsideration on
House Bill 71. not second that okay so
that uh Madam Kirk at the top there were
on reconsideration just on the
reconsideration vote only
yeah
made by representative cordelli and
second by representative luno
has any any discussion here on the
reconsideration
clerk would you please call the roll
Vice chairman cordelli yes
representative leckis yes representative
Ford yes representative Belcher yes
representative notter yes representative
McDonald yes representative Noble yes
representative pedernal yes
representative courtiello yes
representative miler
representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner yes representative
blue now yes representative Ellison yes
representative Woodcock yeah
representative Morton yes representative
Balboni yes representative cascadden yes
representative Damon yes chairman Ladd
yes
20 years zero news thank you
representative Ford you're recognized
for a motion
move out to pass
the second represent myler's makes the
second on that
discussion from the maker of the motion
I think we discussed this pretty well
already but I have nothing really
further to add to it okay representative
okay any further discussion from members
of the committee
not see any
I'm Adam Clark
Vice chairman cordelli yes
representative leckis yes representative
Ford yes representative Belcher yes
representative naughter yes
representative McDonald yes
representative Noble yes
representative yes representative
cortiela yes representative Miler yes
representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner no
representative Luna yes
representative Ellison yes
representative Wilcox yes
representative Morton
yes
representative Balboni no
Representative cascadden no
representative Damon no
chairman Ladd yes
16 yay is four Nays
will there be a Minority Report
no no
they representative for you will make
that report
next bill down on the docket here is one
six eight this is relative to Surety and
Demon vacation for career schools
representative Cornelia recognized for a
motion
I would like to move out to pass is
there a second
representative's second Sam motion
motion made by represent cordelli second
by Lucas
representative cordelli
uh thank you I I believe we had two
uh bills related to uh this topic uh the
other bill
um we retained I think it was 155.
um
right we retained that one and uh
wanted to move ahead with this one
um the uh houseboat 155 we retained so
that if anything happened to this one
along the way we had 155 in our back
pocket
um this basically was
relative to The Surety bonds required
for a career schools
this was the recommendation of the
department
and the hope that it would allow
additional schools to have the necessary
funds to uh get the surety bond and
increase possibly in the future the
number of career schools that will be
approved so that's the reason for the
ought to pass motion
further discussion
representative Miler yes I as we looked
at this obviously the concern that we
have
is to make sure the um students don't
get uh
hung with a bill if in fact the career
school should uh go under
and what we really would like to do is
we would like to have somebody come in
we're not sure whether this is a 10 of
this particular Bill yes we're not sure
whether 10 percent is is an appropriate
withhold
or insurance that they should have and I
think during our conversation we talked
about the need
to have somebody like primex come in and
and kind of inform the committee of
exactly what is should it be 10 maybe it
should be 20 or maybe 50 we don't know
whether 10 is the appropriate amount and
so
um I'm going to be voting against the
OTP in the hopes that we can move this
to a retain and put it within the same
category as we did 155 and during that
retention process as somebody from the
insurance industry come in and at least
give us an indication of what would be
the appropriate thing 10 might be okay
but we don't know that uh and so that's
there's an unsurity here of of exactly
what it should be not neces or not
necessarily opposed to the concept but
we just don't know what what the percent
should be and so Mr chair uh that's what
I'm going to do and hopefully if we have
a 10 10 vote I will then move to to
retain the bill uh and get some more
information so that we can act
appropriately thank you
representative cardelli uh yes I I think
that we had a testimony from uh Mr
Appleby that there's been approximately
uh only foreclosures of career schools
in uh 20 plus years so I think more on a
pretty safe ground with this
any further discussion on this bill
not seeing any Madam clerk would you
please call the roll
Vice chairman cordelli yes
representative Lucas yes representative
Ford yes representative Belcher yes
representative natter yes representative
McDonald yes representative Noble yes
representative pedernal yes
representative cortiela yes
representative Myler
representative Cornell no representative
Tanner no representative Luna no
representative Ellison no representative
Woodcock no representative Morton now
representative Balboni no Representative
cascadden no representative Damon no
chairman Ladd yes
10 years 10 days
Mr chair yes I'd move to retain uh house
bill 168.
is there a second represent Tanner
seconds the motion to retain
retaining motion made by represent miler
perhaps Smiler would like to speak to
your motion I think I have thank you Mr
chair representative Tanner
further discussion on retaining this
bill
sure representative Luna so thank you
very much and uh Mr chair as as
representative cordelli um uh remarked
uh just a few moments ago uh over the
last couple of decades there have been
foreclosures of of career schools in New
Hampshire
um uh we also heard testimony well we
also heard representative cardelli say
that there's a strong interest to um to
to have more career schools come into
New Hampshire so you know based on on
the sen that that playing field we we
could very well see more than than um
than foreclosures what happened to the
um to students um uh prepaid tuition uh
dollars in those foreclosures we don't
know what happened there we don't know
what's going to happen uh down the road
with an increased number of um of of
career schools opening up I think we all
uh recognize the importance of career
schools uh uh coming into the state but
we want to make sure they do it on a
basis that that obviously serves
students as well as our our economy and
uh and I really don't see any um any
drawback to uh to retaining this uh so
that uh so that we can um vote on it in
in January and um knowing that uh that
either 10 is the right amount or whether
it should be eight percent or whether it
should be 15 uh to just have a little
bit more um
um you know technical support from uh uh
from primex on this I think would be
very helpful further discussion from the
committee
I'd like to just say that the bill was
presented by uh director Appleby from
the Department of Education I'm sure
that when they presented something such
as this that they had addressed the
issue of 10 this bill has 10 percent in
and so does 155 and we retain the 155 to
address that very issue but uh
recognizing that uh director Appleby did
simply send this forward to us for
passage I have to assume that they have
a pretty good handle on this and they've
done the inquiry into the 10 percent so
with that I will not vote to retain this
bill
further discussion
Madam clerk would you please call the
role Vice chairman cordelli no
Representative leckis no representative
Ford no representative Belcher no
Representative notter no representative
McDonald no representative Noble no but
representative Peter now no
representative Court yellow no
representative Miler yes
representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner yes representative
Luna yes representative Ellison yes
representative Wilcox yes representative
Morton yes representative Balboni yes
representative cascaden yes
representative Damon yes
chairman Ladd no
10 years 10 days
are there any further motions
I'll move uh itl
is there a second to itl exactly
have represent Damon uh made by uh
representative luno second by
representative Damon
motion is itl
any further discussion from the
committee
sure
go ahead thank you Mr chair
um
you know I I don't I I mean I I
you know I think the recommend a
recommendation of itl uh would not have
been my my first choice I think
retaining would have been by far my
first choice uh I don't have any reason
to believe 10 percent is is not a good
number but I don't have any reason to
believe that it is because we did not
have the testimony
um uh that other than but from um from
Mr Mr Appleby uh with respect to um to
this to this bill and um I think coming
from uh you know at least four four
years that I spent on the um on the
Commerce and consumer affairs committee
uh and spending a lot of time with the
Department of Justice
um uh consumer protection division chief
that uh that you know this is an area
that New Hampshire has to take very
seriously
um uh I I would you know if I I know
we've got a busy two weeks ahead this
week and then the first part of next
week where we I think we have to have
all our bills out right by the 16th by
the 16th yeah
um I don't know if we could if we could
push this one to recess the exec and and
maybe get even getting some written
testimony from primex could be helpful
um and and then we could uh we could
reconsider the ought to pass motion and
and move forward with it but I I just
feel real squishy about it right now
further discussion
is emotionally recessed this and Army is
a motion to reset system
there's an idea on the floor we've come
down to this point before
um and
what you could do is you could ask for a
reconsideration on your last vote and
then we could recess it and so the vote
your vote would have been a retain or on
in the case the other side to OTP but
that during the time if we bring it up
then again
like we could do it tomorrow
or in in a prime X if uh director
Appleby could be contacted uh could we
find out uh what's the difference
between ten percent twenty percent fifty
percent
um I don't know myself
uh but it basically it depends upon the
tuition for that particular uh uh
organization right right so so Mr chair
if we could if we could get some some at
least better visibility to to how the 10
was arrived at and what other things
were considered and and yes you know if
primex is in support of that uh then uh
then you know this committee may be in a
position to ought to pass this
um you know with a strong bipartisan
vote but but if you're suggesting that
maybe we could um reach out we could
email
um Mr Appleby uh to get some some even a
paragraph of written testimony I'd be
happy to withdraw my motion okay we can
have that information back from director
Appleby by you know Wednesday
so if you want to read I'll withdraw the
itl motion and who made the second on
that represent Damon okay great so with
that we're going to recess this hearing
until a time to be announced based upon
our report back from uh director Appleby
I'll reach out to him so thank you very
much Mr chair you're welcome I
appreciate it and representative Damon
it's clarification will we hear from
primex as well as Mr Appleby that would
be part of the request thank you
and representative cordelli will contact
director Appleby on that and Applebee
can then contact primax
yeah yep
all right
um going on down to the next bill 377.
this is a bill relative to screening and
intervention in public schools for
dyslexia and Related Disorders uh
representative Cordelia recognized for a
motion I move out to pass
is there a second on the ought to pass
representative Tanner seconds the ought
to pass
um
yeah let's let the the uh person made
the motion talk first uh representative
cordelli do you have any discussion on
um uh I I think it is probably a step
forward in terms of uh testing our
children for dyslexia
um I'm interested in seeing what the
amendment might show as we have one
Amendment on the table already
um
that's it
well we have the bill on the table we
don't have any Amendment on the table at
this point yes on the table and uh
represent 10 are you talking about zero
three set five seven uh zero five one
six H okay that's a new one
okay reps and Tanner you're recognized
so um this new new Amendment what it
does is it takes out the uh Financial
part of this bill which was
um kind of problem can you hold on just
a second until everybody gets it I'm
sorry
thank you
now for everybody make sure you have the
right amendment I have on record several
other amendments which we've had on this
yeah we've had zero two three four and
zero three five seven and now we're
dealing with zero five one six
representative Tanner thank you thank
you so
um I've been in contact with this
sponsor the bill uh representative catab
and also uh representative Ebel and a
person uh who actually testified
um BB Casey and Karen and Bibi were both
instrumental in getting the first
dyslexic Bill through so we've been
we've been kind of uh back and forth and
And discussing this and trying to get
something that we thought uh would be
palatable to everybody and yet achieve
the two purposes that we have the two
purposes are more testing for dyslexia
and also immediate intervention or or
soon intervention so basically this this
um Amendment takes out uh the diables um
uh reference that that we've had before
and just use evidence-based screener for
identification
and
um the rest of it I think you've seen
before in the other the other ones we
changed some of the um dates uh we took
out uh January 1st and and did the
initial screening shall be completed no
later than 60 school days of a student
entering public school and that was uh
to cover students who come in uh not
right at in September
um and the um intervention uh was the
next part of it
um that that secondary assessment within
30 days was the second testing and then
there would be
[Music]
um
intervention
initiated within 21 days of the initial
screening if they tested positive as
well we've you can see charter schools
have have been mentioned in this where
before they weren't uh they were they
were mentioned in the first
part but um we've also continued that
down into section two
and then the big difference between this
and the last two amendments were that
have taken out the financial uh note
where we tried to get the amount of
money that was given to a school after
third grade if someone hadn't reached
proficiency uh we were trying to
incorporate that as a incentive for uh
or to give money to schools for the um
intervention but we took that out
because we feel that schools now have
the ability to do interventions a lot of
them are trained and schools once
they're aware of the dyslexia issue have
been able to meet it so it no longer
probably should have a financial note
because it doesn't
so that's basically the changes
representative Tanner I see online
30 or excuse me 29.
uh you did make the change and I think
it's a positive change
during this time general education
accommodations
uh and it once read during this time
general education intervention right so
intervention really is the wrong word
there right accommodation would be a
better terminology yes and it it makes
it that's another reason for renewing
the financial note the accommodations
again are something that's ongoing in in
public schools and charter schools
further discussion
representative cascaden thank you Mr
chair just want to add
um to keep in mind the scores that were
published recently that showed the
decrease in kids performance in Reading
really can be related back to the times
that schools were closed for covid so if
you have a kindergartner that got done
kindergarten in March and then had
remote the whole following year and then
come to school on in grade two
the scores are going to be substantially
low because of that that Gap so I think
this bill is very needed because it is
very targeted and more directed
I'm a little disheartened that RSA 259
did not work for that purpose but I
think this bill would so I would support
it further discussion
so at this point in time we have the
amendment on the floor
and that's Amendment zero five one six H
is there any further discussion on this
amendment
yes representative Mr chair just to be
clear
um this bill has not been amended by any
of the preceding amendments either is
that correct that that is correct okay
thank you
so I would like to move that as an ought
to pass on my Amendment okay is there a
second to the amendment representative
so we have a motion on the table for the
amendment that's just been spoken to
zero five one six H made by
representative Tanner and second by
representative Lucas
further discussion
not seeing any uh Madam Clerk
Vice chairman cordelli yes
representative Lucas yes representative
Ford yeah representative Belcher no
representative Nader yes
representative McDonald yes
representative Noble
yes representative pedernal yes
representative courtiello yes
representative Myler yes
representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner yes representative
Luna yes representative Ellison yes
representative Woodcock yeah
representative Morton yes representative
Balboni yes representative cascadden
representative Damon yes
yes
19 years one day
recognized for a motion uh yes I like to
move a lot to pass as amended with
Amendment 0-516h
I'd like to section Montana thank you
cordelli Tanner and then that
further discussion from representative
cardelli
nothing further represent Tanner
yes I'd just like to say thank you for
the support on the amendment and
hopefully the support for the the bill
um this is a life-changing Bill uh
students who cannot read because they
have dyslexia
um or another impediment
um once they get to you know school and
they're in second and third grade and
fourth grade they're still struggling to
learn to read while their classmates are
reading to learn and that's how they
fall behind and they may never catch up
and it's a life-altering so thank you
and just a comment I'm sure that
honorable Jack Balcom is looking up atop
of this down on us and saying thank you
further discussion
Madam Clerk
Vice chairman cordelli yes
representative lekkas yes representative
Ford yes representative Belcher no
representative naughter yes
representative McDonald yes
representative Noble yes representative
pedernal yes representative cortiello
yes representative Miler yes
representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner yes representative
luno yes representative Ellison yes
representative yes representative Morton
yes representative Balboni yes
representative cascadden yes
representative Damon yes
chairman last yes 19 years one day
any objections to consent
will there be a Minority Report I'm not
in consent
thank you very much
the next spell word
representative cordelli will represent
Tanner yeah representative Tanner and
representative cornelli will get
together and write that report
okay we're jumping over 382 as that has
been done and completed earlier
uh so now we're down on
um three no see don't worry oh see we
have 382
allowing for a testing exception for
graduation from high school represent
Belcher
thank you Mr chair I would note that we
just received um an amendment that went
around to this I've reviewed it
um I believe it fixes some of the
problems but I believe some language
still needs to be cleaned up uh as such
okay women they don't have the amendment
yet we're just going this way
do you represent cascadden did you pass
around tall that way
as your name no wait a minute this
represented yeah that's not true I was
looking at the I need that dyslexia
do you
I just looked too quickly at it we don't
have enough
I would further note that this amendment
was provided by the uh representative
originating the bill
um as such it's not a committee
um Amendment so it can't be adopted by
us at this time unless one of us were to
go do this I believe
that's why oh okay
in any case
um unless somebody else objects I would
say this still needs a little bit of
cleanup so I would move to retain
to retain
per second by representative cornelli
represent Belcher do you want to speak
to your motion yes um referencing the
original Bill there was a very good
concept I believe in this but there was
a number of items that uh needed to be
cleaned up the amendment here
um I'd like to look very closely at and
make a few minor changes at um to
possibly try to get this past next year
I don't think there's a need for high
achieving students the the next Elon
Musk of the world to be sitting
unnecessarily
um probably developing behavioral
problems
um instead of moving on and and building
the future for us
so I'd like to retain this and work on
this so we can get this through next
year
question
representative
cordelli you made the second do you have
any nothing further Jefferson Ellison uh
just not starting the discussion about
the amendment but when I was at the
department of edit I was in charge of
administering the high school
equivalency test uh the current status
of that is that it's fairly easy for any
16 or 17 year old to take the high
school equivalency test at this point
with the approval of the parents and the
approval of the school so I that'll just
be part of the discussions I guess is
when we get to it indeed thank you
further discussion
[Applause]
I had one concern in receiving the sheet
that we all received from the New
Hampshire school boards Association from
Rebecca Wilson I don't know if we re
you've received that
um and I'll read it generally you must
be at least 18 years old to take the
hiset but Most states have Pro visions
that allow 17 year olds to take the test
if they obtain a waiver certain States
even allow students as young as 16 to
take the test as several additional
criteria are met the exact requirements
for each state are are in the uh
connection or the
link here the hiset consists of five
different subtests covering the core
subjects of the typical high school
curriculum the questions are all
multiple choice except for one essay
question students normally take the exam
on a computer but a paper version is
available as well the test is available
in either English or Spanish so that was
a communication there my concerns are
that
if in fact the state gets into the
business of having to develop a test
like this or an assessment
we're talking about a huge amount of
work in terms of a lot of finances
associated with to identify than to
ensure that the test is matching all the
standards associated with academic
performance in the state and also
matching up to those required courses
for graduation
so there's a trend and you'd have to
have different forms of the test too so
that you can't give the same version of
the test right after you all you have to
have various different versions of that
to them and ensure it's um
um uh a test which is uh got back up so
that you don't are you're not repetitive
and so it's valid so I do have some
concerns about this whole process I
think we're we're getting down into the
age bracket where it's very difficult to
ascertain that this would have to be an
I was assuming an extremely gifted
individual to be able to test out of
high school at age 13.
further discussion represent Belcher yes
and just to speak to your point I agree
with a lot of what you just said and I
think part of the change that is going
to need to be made would be to instead
of instead of mandating a design test to
be able to designate
um a test and I think we can look and
examine what tests may be out there that
might be appropriate I recall and I
don't know how they are these days but I
recall taking the sat2s they offer for
various subjects and they uh they grade
them according to different percentiles
so that may be something we can look at
and other things as well
further discussion representative
Woodcock it's just a question for
Reverend velcro if I may so Mike is the
intent the intent
um primarily the age change or is the
intent the doe taking it over
I I think we can put everything up for
discussion to where we want to kind of
fine-tune this thing if 13 is
objectionable I I don't really have a
problem with 13 but if we want to look
at 14 or 15 or something like that if
that if that's what it takes to get it
passed I'll be fine looking at that but
I think there was a number of tweaks
that needed to be made and I think we
should put everything on the table
thank you further discussion
the motion on the table up front of us
right now is to retain this bill
no not see any further discussion Madam
clerk would you please call a roll
please
3.99 allowing for testing exception for
graduation from high school
Vice chairman cordelli yes
representative leckis yes representative
Ford yes representative Belcher yes
representative notter yes representative
McDonald yes representative Noble yes
representative yes representative yes
representative Myler no
representative Cornell no
representative Tanner no
representative Luna no
representative Ellison
representative Woodcock no
representative Morton no representative
Balboni no representative Cascade no
representative Damon no chairman Ladd
yes
10 years 10 days
for the motions
is there a second
motion made by reference second by
represent Damon to itl 399
further discussion
yes representative I also think this is
uh actually trying to be placed under
the wrong place in the statute so this
is uh under a statute that talks about
compulsory education
um and I'm not sure testing out is is
there plus
you know we spent
wonderful time on having Pace
um performance-based assessments and uh
it's very difficult to do in a test like
this so thanks
further discussion
I'd like to just discuss it a little bit
um
if you're looking we're looking now at
the primary bill as it was introduced
and I'm looking at lines 24 through 26
any child aged 13 or older whether a
citizen of New Hampshire or elsewhere
may take the test any child who passes
the test shall be issued a high school
diploma equivalency certificate and be
accepted from compulsory School
attendance issues
it goes on down further and says that
the results of this are going to be what
guaranteed by our University system or
post-secondary education system we've
had no communication from the
post-secondary education system whether
they do that or not we're having a hard
time getting Community College courses
transferred and accepted at the
University system New Hampshire
now we're talking about something that a
13 year old does so I have real
misgivings of even going forward with
this bill at this time
further discussion
representative Cornell I
as a former middle school guidance
counselor a 13 year old is a seventh
grader and in my mind a seventh grader
testing out of school and
not going to a secondary school because
we have no indication that they're going
to be accepted I don't know what they'll
be doing and I just have visions of them
sitting home and babysitting or with I
think everybody's been reading in the
paper or seen on the news the employment
of underage kids working midnight shifts
places and if they're out of school none
of that I guess applies to them anymore
because they can just go to work 40
hours a week someplace
and I I think 13 is just too young for
something like that to be happening
with or without parental permission so I
I
just find this
upsetting that's all representative
Belcher thank you Mr chair I actually
had a question uh for you or for anybody
who could possibly answer this given the
amendment that was just put before us if
this bill were to be killed today is
this amendment sufficiently different
from the original bill that it can be
reintroduced by the original
representative next year
no I I it will not be able to be uh put
forth in the second year of the biennium
okay it's too too close to what we have
right here thank you
represent Lucas and then representative
cascadden
the idea of behind being able to test
out of compulsory High School attendance
at the age of 13 is not for the kid to
be on their own or anything else it's
for them to be able to follow whatever
interests or passions they have if you
have a gifted musician and I know of
some
um who are already at that age
symphonic capable right
um
why should it if they if they have shown
that they understand all of the high
school stuff by taking the test why
should they have to be spending their
time doing that instead of working on
whatever the instrument is and working
with an orchestra
that's still supervised it's still
education it's still but it's no longer
sitting learning the things or sitting
through the presentation of the things
they already know and so the idea is yes
it's probably going to be as somebody
said they'd have to be gifted to pass
this that's the point
and the point is if they have an area of
particular gifting why if they already
know all this information why should
they be sitting through school instead
of pursuing whatever area that is
whether it's engineering or music or
whatever area that is why should they
not be able to use those years pursuing
that and getting better at that and
contributing sooner as an as once they
are adults
so that's the idea it's not sitting at
home on their own working whatever it's
the ability to pursue whatever their
gifted area is thank you and I'd like to
follow up a little bit here
I think there's a lot of information
here in concept wise
it has some good points however when you
leave read the last sentence
on page one and continue on to page two
I have real problems with it and it says
any non-profit institution of higher uh
learning in New Hampshire that offers
and Associates or bachelor's degree that
does not accept a passing score in this
test as sufficient for matriculation or
which impose burdensome regulations for
graduation that subvert the intent of
this law shall be subject to having its
state funding reduced or removed by the
general court that's one heck of a
threat and I don't think that is going
to really carry over that well with the
university system New Hampshire UNH
Keane Plymouth
Etc
representative cascadden thank you Mr
chair uh just want to add that we put so
much focus on a test it's only one
moment in time
and if the student does really well so
be it but for a high school diploma
you're dumming down
the value of that diploma and really it
doesn't determine the Mastery of the
competencies because I have to
demonstrate them oftentimes
in some some form
um there's also no Assurance of work
study practices that are required or
Proficiency in any of the content areas
so it's a lot more than being a heavy
knowledge base on one particular day at
one time however I understand the
scenario of someone who may track in a
professional World whether it's music or
dance or Sports
or even someone who's on the Olympic
team
they have private tutors or there are
arrangements made for them so if you
have a student who's exceptional in
music and going down that path you still
want them to have some sort of a
well-rounded education so they can
function in life outside of that world
of music but not to deter it so again
one moment in time is a test that's it
further representative
the point of retaining is because yes
there are things like that paragraph
that should not be in there but if we
itl it we can't fix it
and if we if we don't pass the Ito then
we still have the ability to fix it and
take out those objectional parts and
figure out how to make it better so I
would seriously recommend not idealing
it so we can keep working on it
otherwise it's dead we can't do anything
next year either thank you represent
cordelli uh thank you
um yeah I have problems with Roman 3
um a even in the amendment
um a citizen of New Hampshire or
elsewhere is a uh accepted from uh
compulsory I assume New Hampshire
attendance laws I don't know why someone
from another state would be exempt from
New Hampshire School attendance laws and
as has already been discussed B and C I
think are very problematic
um
I I like the concept you know we've seen
stories uh recently even of um uh very
intelligent children
um 14 15 years old graduating with uh
high school and Associates degrees
um so I I I think this is in line with
uh maybe my view of what was the
original intent of uh uh our um
competency program Mastery Program if
you will
um I I think it does need work
um I'm not sure and ought to pass
um what work could be done where and
when on it to correct the problems
um you know a floor amendment in the
house I think would not be workable on
this this bill and I'm not sure how the
Senate would
react to this and trying to work on it
in the Senate so I'm disappointed that
the retained motion did not pass and I'm
not sure of my vote on the itl
rep Santana
just as a word from a practitioner for
been in public school for a long time
and to follow up on representative
cascaden we had numerous students who
were really good at skiing who went to a
ski Academy for several months during
the winter time and they still got their
high school work done because we would
the high school itself would would
provide the the work and they had tutors
at the at the school and when they came
back they were able to certify that they
had actually taken that we had a young
lady that just graduated from cursage
that actually swam the English Channel
swam the Catalina
did a tremendous uh swimming uh
performance was able to do that well
within the high school
situation and the high school and
teachers made accommodations when she
needed to leave for different training
purposes and as you said the even the
Olympic program has tutors and works
with the local schools so
also if a student is very gifted my
experience at a high school is that they
can fast track them through high school
by taking the core credits and be off to
college you know in their junior year or
whatever so I think that public schools
make accommodations for this
representative Woodcock thank you
chairman and I would I would follow up
with representative cascadians and and
Tanner's uh comments uh in that when I
was last time I was at uh working in
high school in New Hampshire I was
responsible for part of that programming
how they do that I would say that uh the
intent uh of Representative belcher's uh
piece that's what I was trying to get
through my asses specifically if the
concern is really age and all else fails
the parents still if they have the
student that is so exceptional and
there's nothing in their rsas and they
don't prefer to go through high school
they always have the right to withdraw
the student as a home Schooler and put
them in a private program anywhere they
want to do it so it's it's not like
we're saying geez I I understand where
they are coming from you have if you
have this one student out of 160 000
that's ready to roll uh the parents said
the right to do that and and and then
probably their parents I would guess on
the aside we have students with them and
if want this I think there is
an option for parents out here as well
as uh the rest of the school system I I
don't think there's any need to go back
to this at this point in time and I do
have a concern as uh representative uh
from Manchester said uh the youngster
who are 13 years old uh theme of
throwing off to handle this but I do
think parents we had one exceptional kid
do have an option if all this fails Mr
chair thank you further discussion
representative McDonald
thank you I just wanted to add into the
conversation another option that we
haven't mentioned is the availability of
dual and concurrent enrollment so
options do exist for these students that
are high achieving
and with that you can come out with an
associate's degree from high school
or two years as freshman sophomore
in U.S University of New Hampshire
further discussion
represent Belcher thank you Mr chair
just very briefly I think the real
intent behind this bill is to look at
the the history of very high achieving
people and so often what you find is
that they they couldn't tolerate just
sitting around and they dropped out of
high school
and they a lot of them were very
successful nonetheless but what has
changed today is that we now live
unfortunately I think in a society where
credentials mean a lot more than what
you're capable of in a lot of instances
and somebody who's dropping out of high
school who now doesn't have a high
school diploma despite the fact that
they're gifted they're going to be
severely handicapped when it comes to
moving on with their life and doing good
things unfortunately just because of
that credential and I think that's what
this is meant to address
further discussion from the committee
ma'am clerk would you please call the
roll
Vice chairman cordelli yes
Representative leckis no
representative Ford
this is on it oh yes well to itl itl is
the motion on the floor okay
no
representative Belcher no
representative notter
guess
representative McDonald yes
representative Noble no
Representative pedernal no
Representative cortiello no
representative Miler yes
representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner yes representative
blue now yes representative Ellison yes
representative Woodcock yes
representative Morton yes representative
Balboni yes representative cascadden yes
representative Damon yes
chairman lad yes
14 years six Nays
will there be a Minority Report
who's writing it
Belcher okay
completed by the time you leave tonight
so I didn't volunteer okay
next bill on the docket here
does anybody have to take a five minute
break here yes yeah yes okay I sense
that so let's
I'm samsonia too
okay we'll take a 10 minute break
foreign
okay we're going to pick up the uh exact
sessions right now and we're going to go
back to HB
168 relative to Surety and
indemnification for career schools and
for discussion purposes uh I'm going to
have representative cordelli just
finished talking with director Appleby
regarding primex and uh getting in that
insurance stuff
um so representative cordelli thank you
Mr chairman uh yes I talked with
director Appleby just now and um
explained where we were with the bill
and he did not think that he was going
to be able to
explain everything to primex or other
insurance carrier
um in a short time frame
um and we discussed the fact that we
have HB 155 already retained which does
something similar with the surety bond
so I think the recommendation is that we
itl 168 and work on 155 as our vehicle
for moving forward with the surety bond
issue
so Madam clerk where are we where were
we as far as the last motion we made
on 168.
it's the motion itl yeah I think
um yeah oh I'm sorry okay I just was
looking the last one because I crossed
it out with itl withdrawn so but I
crossed it all out so I was looking at
above that where we it was okay so
represent cardellion gonna recognize you
for a motion
uh thank you Mr chairman I move itl on
House Bill 168. is there a second
representative Meyer seconds the motion
to itl 168.
further discussion
not seeing any Madam clerk just when
you're ready
Vice chairman cordelli yes
representative blackis yes
representative Ford yes representative
Belcher yes representative Nutter yes
representative McDonald yes
representative Noble yes representative
pedernal yes representative corridiello
yes representative Miler yes
representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner yes representative
luno yes representative Ellison yes
representative Wilcox yes representative
representative about money yes
representative cascadden yes
representative Damon yes chairman yes
28 zero Nays very good good with consent
yes thank you okay uh going down below
where we dropped off on that 399 last
bill we did
uh 517 as you recall at the beginning
here that's when we already have done
went out ought to pass 19 to zero
represent Myler had made that motion
um so jumping over five one seven down
to five two eight
relative to school lunches and
establishing the meals for students fun
representative beltry recognized for a
motion
thank you Mr chair I would move IPL
is there a second second
there was a second made by repson
whitcock and motion made by
representative Belcher uh representative
Belcher you can speak to your motion on
528. thank you Mr chair
um this bill would
um establish requirements on schools for
serving breakfast and lunch as parts of
the school lunch program we've seen
other bills this session
um that would do the same requirement
and we have ideal those bills as well
because this is an unnecessary
requirement to be placing on schools uh
it comes with a lot of cost
um and it's just it's it's not a good
bill at this time representative
woodcock
thank you Mr chair I uh appreciate the
comments from representative Belcher
although I I don't agree with them
primarily
um I would say I do agree with the ideal
moment that's not the rationale for it
um I think School meals are a
significant issue right now I think food
is security for youngsters in school the
same information right now I do agree
that this bill is very confusing it has
multiple parts that don't really fly
right now and that there Still Remains
as representative Lucas and and Floyd
and I and uh Miss Allison from the
summer worked uh exorbitantly and
consistently on providing getting
information and studying this and there
is yet another bill to come that is uh
significantly more meaningful uh and and
able to be uh hopefully uh uh passed uh
by this committee and then the house to
help students in schools and school
meals so I would agree with my associate
from Carroll County that this bill
should be ideal but for a different
rationale
further discussion
represent luno thank you very much Mr
chair um just a question to the chair if
um if both those rationales could be
included in the um in the committee
report
with some collaboration well the maker
and the motion represent Belcher would
you be willing to put both rationales
into your report
absolutely thank you
I'd be happy to have him do it for me
thank you
well please be collaborative
there was also a fiscal note which they
could not determine what the cost of the
program would be that's might be noted
as well
further discussion on the bill
Madam Clerk
we're on HB 528 relative to school
lunches and establishing the meals for
students fund
thanks chairman cordelli yes
representative like us yes
representative Ford yes representative
Belcher yes representative Nutter yes
representative McDonald yes
representative Noble yes representative
pedernal yes representative cortielo yes
representative Miler yes representative
Cornell yes representative Tanner yes
representative Luna yes representative
Ellison yes representative Wilcox yes
representative Morton yes representative
yes representative cascadin yes
representative Damon yes chairman lad
yes
28 zero Nas
any objections to consent
thank you
the next bill which we have is 536
relative to the Charter Public School
joint legislative oversight committee
I'm going to hand the capital over to
um representative cordelli thank you Mr
chairman uh call on chairman Ladd for a
motion yes I'd recommend OTP on 536 uh
is there a second
representative Tanner seconds
discussion from the maker yes
um although there are some change that I
think the most significant need for this
bill is that the committee meet
um
the uh committee uh
was started my my recollection here is
that the back in 1995 and going forward
through all those years there's a page
and a half right there in meetings but
then all of a sudden in 2015 they stop
and we've had I it's obvious they had
these meetings when Charter Schools were
were being started in the state and the
funding source was being arrived at now
we have uh issues which with all our
areas of Education we need some
oversight as a legislative body
and at this point in time yes the State
Board of Education addresses the issue
of charter schools and they have even
rejected some of the proposals that have
come before them
um however I feel at this time that it's
time to get this committee is active
again in fact one of the persons that's
noted on the log here as representing
education as John rist rist
in my 15 years being on this committee
I've never recalled that name being on
this committee
um but Bruce Ward's name is there Kim
Weiler's name is uh Denise Riccardi's
there and John Hunt who's not on
education is on that so we need to
really revamp this get it working so we
can get some reports in to us on the
July 1 date that's indicated in this
bill
uh yes representative Myler thank you Mr
chair
thank you uh representative Ladd for
moving this this is an important bill I
mean we have in my 10-year uh on this
committee
we have moved from 18 charter schools to
30 charter schools and in that period of
time we've had three that have failed
primarily for for lack of interest in
the content and also from the from a
fiscal standpoint
as we expand these Charter Schools
we need to make sure that there is some
oversight it is a commonplace
before the State Board of Education to
have concerns about governance of these
schools that come before complaints
about governance we
we're successful uh several years ago
and getting a designated staff member I
was I was one of the ones who worked
with Senator felthus and getting that
through again another example of
providing uh those who want to have
Charter Schools uh develop their
proposal Etc as well as dealing with the
governance questions around those
schools and what I mean about governance
is that one of the problems you have in
charter schools you have a dedicated
group of people who create the charter
school and then as new parents come into
that charter school they want to be
involved in the governance but those who
created it don't want to give up their
sense of ownership to it and then that
can be a problem and it has been a
problem so I think this oversight
committee will help as representative
Ladd said meet on a regular basis this
is not a gotcha bill this is a bill that
provides some sense of oversight and
guidance for charter schools that we
just have not had since the initial
Inception of these things in in the mid
90s so I would encourage people to vote
for this because I think it will help
charter schools be more effective in
their mission as they work with their
students thank you Mr chair
thank you
for you oh okay so so uh I'd like to add
on to that that initially when Charter
Schools their Public Schools
and they were developed uh on the
federal level for the purpose of
innovation and and taking uh ideas and
ways operating and sharing it with all
public schools and with that I think
this uh particular committee right here
oversight would have the responsibility
to communicate some of those areas which
are the strengths and to share those
strengths of instruction and curriculum
with uh uh like we do with the oversight
we have of improvement and assessment
for all public education so I think it's
a need to get this committee working and
so we can share in our responsibility
for trying to improve legislation our
legislation education throughout the
state
any yes representative Ellison I just
just a point to to clarify the
membership for prior committees there is
a John rist he's former principal of
Central High School
thank you very much represent Allison
further comments from the committee
I've seen none Madam Clerk
Vice chairman cordelli
yes
representative lekkas yes
representative Ford yes representative
Belcher yes
representative Nutter yes representative
McDonald yes representative Noble yes
representative pedernal yes
representative cortielo yes
representative Miler yes
representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner yes representative
luno yes representative Ellison yes
representative Wilcock yes
representative Martin yes representative
Balboni yes representative cascadin yes
representative Damon yes
chairman LED yes
20 years
any concerns with consent thank you
thank you what we're going to do right
now we're going to take a short talk
because we never got the last three
bills uh in the caucus we had we'd like
to take about 15 minutes here go through
that and then come through back and
finish up our exact session for the day
we could get out by noon time it'd be
great
it's always thrilling
thank you
so I need to go back to this one
which one no I just got to make sure all
my my eyes are dotted and so so okay
uh thank you Mr chairman I would like to
move out to pass
I'll second
pattern now okay okay uh representative
now makes the second to the motion made
by representative cordelli on 553
relative to school district information
on Personnel salaries representative
cardelli uh thank you
um the intent with this um bill is
basically uh transparency
for many people
um the public and school personnel as
well
um it's my understanding that some
districts might publish the information
as part of their annual report but I
think it it would be uh very helpful to
have the information
of the position and salary uh posted on
the district website it could be a
listing it could be a a PDF document
that's posted I do not think it is
burdensome but I think even teachers
would be interested in looking at the
district or the school
salary structure
and we've heard a lot about teacher
salaries in the state they've been
op-eds Etc recently about teacher
salaries there's a Senate Bill related
to teacher salaries and I think this
would be
an easy way to provide information
Nation about
the entire salary
structure within a school
further discussion
thank you Mr chair
um
I I have serious concerns about this
bill uh I the collective buying
Agreements are available publicly the uh
School accounts are available publicly
um those pieces when you stop putting
people's names and salary uh
particularly in small towns uh like
teachers on a website I think this has a
real to me it's a real negative intent I
don't see it as a positive piece at all
people can access information they have
it and as Glenn mentioned already in
some of the annual reports there are
other ways to access it uh through the
CPAs and and through the warrants when
they voted I think this puts teachers
and supervisors and administrators just
a continued negative light in many
communities particularly those that are
struggling financially I I just I have a
real I I think there's limited good if
anything can come from this thing thank
you
thank you from personal experience at
one point during negotiations a while
ago they published all our our salaries
our names are our degrees
in the paper
and the result of that
um was kind of mixed a lot of teachers
felt embarrassed that people found out
how little they made that was one thing
but it it really did do exactly what you
just said representative Woodcock um you
know we had eight towns and Care
Sergeant some of them are pretty small
and uh it it was really tough on a lot
of people and and uh people were getting
accosted in the in the supermarket and
that sort of thing and I also uh had a
lot of comments from people who work in
business who said I can't believe you're
they're doing this because in a business
or anything else can you imagine and a
lot of you have worked outside of
schools you imagine having your your
salary published in the paper
and what that might mean so
representative cordelli uh thank you
um the intent was the position not the
individual's name
so uh be third grade teacher a or Etc
the position
um and the salary even though I think
that teacher names are and their
salaries are public information and
would be available on a 91a request
that's pretty young
well taxpayers are paying these salaries
so they have every right to know where
their money is going and it is public
information they can access it through
annual reports and such
um however this improves the access to
information some towns don't publish
this in their annual reports so it
increases transparency but most of all
it's improving access to information so
I'm obviously for that thanks
thank you
um you know I'm checking with New
Hampshire Municipal resources
um they're already is an established
mechanism
to be able to acquire that knowledge for
somebody who wants it
um because the law that's followed again
is somebody already mentioned is that
yes
um there has to be transparency of
government
um and how the taxpayers money is spent
and that right is already available
under the right to no law
so no this this bill putting you know
positions of a certain
group of people and not everybody who's
an employee of the city or the town
really is tacky
thank you Mr chair
so we just voted this morning to
repeal
making it easier to see
Charter School payments
and it feels to me like the same people
who thought it was okay to repeal easier
access to those payments
think we should make it easier to access
these salaries
I find a discrepancy in that
thank you
um information can be available
um
via 91a request but I think it is burden
it is a difficult process for many
um and that
it really is not
what the uh intent of this is the the
intent of this is to make it uh the
information easily accessible to people
as several people have mentioned some
districts might publish it in their
annual report
um which is a step forward but I think
having it available on the website makes
it much more available to people
staff you know might well be interested
in seeing what
administrators are making as opposed to
the teachers in the classroom
represent cascadden that information is
made public when a line by line on an
item budget presentation is provided to
the public so that that is example is is
already there
um but this bill is also discriminatory
you're only targeting a certain group
just to create negativity and to make
the public school look
in a negative light again
represent cordelli it is certainly not
my intention with this bill to put
public schools in any negative light
that's not the intention at all the
intention is to make salary information
available as I said earlier uh teacher
salaries are an issue we've seen it over
and over again and I think that this
would be maybe enlightening information
to some teachers working in this school
to see how much others in the school are
making
but it's certainly not an attention to
put anybody or anything in a negative
light
representative Tanner
just as a response uh teachers know what
other teachers are making because it is
public information and because it is on
a line item budget and and
um
it's also collective bargaining so
teachers are well aware of what other
teachers are making
I'd like to take a moment and then
representative luno you can speak I
brought in my town report right here
everything is in the town report there's
12 pages of salaries in here name of the
individual I'm not the individuals
getting paid and the position the person
is in not just for teachers it even has
substitute teachers listed in this it
has any any dollars which go out for any
other reason be it a stipend for
athletics or it be it
um a bonus a holiday bonus which they
had and I found that over the years and
just open up what this is helpful
information in terms of when you're on
the advice budget advisory committee to
be looking at this and know where you
are what I learned from this is that
my Town's not competitive
with towns south of us like Lebanon or
even with Littleton
um or Hanover we are for the same
teaching job in many some cases of
twenty thousand dollars shy and this is
one of the reasons why we have our I
have a shortage of teachers in math and
science up my neck of the woods and so
this is in a way I see as informative to
the public yes you know we we have to
address this issue and so because it's
here on all these 12 Pages it goes and
goes and goes
um I don't see any reason why putting on
a web is going to make much difference
um I for one feel that we're transparent
enough with this this goes out to every
person going to the polls to vote or you
can get a copy at the Town Office since
they are available
so
um I I see this as
um
a bill that is trying to do what some
districts are already doing I can't say
that this is on on by way of a PDF on
the website or not but I can guarantee
you that we put it every year I've lived
there right in this book
we used to put in them people are
delinquenting their taxes in the thing
and that's now since gone but this
remains
representative luno thank you very much
Mr chair and and thanks for um um you
know for for showing us that uh
Hopkinton has done that for um for years
as well and uh and they don't need a law
in the plate on the books to um to do
that but but but what one of the things
you talked about
um on that
um representative Vlad was uh was the
the various um uh Personnel that are
that are that are disclosed in there and
that their um their teachers their
support staff their their instructional
age Librarians principals uh uh uh I I
don't know how far that goes if it goes
to um to uh people that may be employed
by the district uh to that provide
transportation uh if it includes if it
includes those positions and I'm
wondering if it might also include
um a position of let's say somebody
that's providing transportation for or a
child with with an IEP being being
transported to a a you know outside of
the district because from time to time I
think those positions are are uh are
filled by uh by members of that
student's family and um and so whether
that would be whether those positions
would have to be disclosed uh by the the
the
um policy in 553 well I can look at one
of them right now I won't say the name
uh it says position special needs bus
monitor non-contract hours Insurance
stipend employee holiday bonus preschool
uh screening and it lists the the money
that this individual receives
right right and and you know so my
concern is that by by clonifying it that
that we the way is the way it is here
that that it may compel disclosure of a
student's mom or dad who may be driving
transporting them into uh to an out of
District
um
um uh service provider
representative
thank you Mr chair I don't think this is
needed it's already in uh in law and it
was cited uh 94 c9a already gives the
opportunity for school districts if they
if they in fact want to do this to have
a warrant article and put it before the
the town if they want to do this they
can vote it in for that particular town
so I don't think uh this uh Universal
application for it is necessary and I'll
be voting no on this OTP
further discussion representative
portiello
so representative Ladd was showing us
the annual report that's really thick
not all annual reports
provide the information on school
salaries so
um just wanted to speak to to that again
this improves access to the information
but also to representative Damon's
pointing out that there's a
contradiction in
voting for House Bill 71
um
and then not supporting this uh one of
the I was just looking at my notes for
71 and something that resonated with me
was that house bill 71 was requested by
the doe and that that along with other
things made me vote that way so there
was no you know I don't think there's
any hypocrisy involved in voting one way
on 71 and then this way on on this bill
represent Myler yeah I've got a question
I'm looking at my notes
and I had
on 224
an exact session
and I had an Ito
by paternal and cordelli
nine to one
am I the only one that has that in my
notes five six what Bill are you on
that's 563 oh I'm in the wrong way
excuse me thank you very much I can't
remember in many 901s yeah okay thank
you very much representative Damon
I see this bill as something that should
be
not passed because it should be up to
local communities what approach to
communicating the information works for
them
we do we defer lots of things to local
control and I think this belongs there
I in fact think in the nine Town
District that I represent
there would be different decisions as to
how the information would be
communicated partly related to the small
population size
invasiveness to professionals that we
should respect
further discussion reps in Woodcock
thank you Carol I just a follow-up on
your Commerce actually
um I think the difference between a
document you're looking at
representative ad and this bill is that
is a non-discriminatory non-biased wide
open every single person that's the way
it is this bill
hones in on one particular group of
people
uh which makes it a bigger concern in
Conway we have similar to yours
representative ad a very detailed
document but that's but that's not this
this is one group of people isolated out
uh for I think uh and and I'll take Glen
at his word that's not a negative intent
but surely it could be a negative action
thank you
represent cordelli uh thank you and uh
thank you for taking me at my word
um uh yeah this is the education
committee so I was bringing forward a
bill related to uh school
um uh salaries uh
um you know if I want next year to bring
a town salary position
um you know I'm sure that will go to
Municipal and County committee
further discussion
I'd like to ask the court where where
are we getting the uh
the idea that we're only talking
teachers here
I wasn't referencing just teachers I
found that where this not only only
deals with school boards uh School staff
and position names that's my point it's
only schools
yeah
this book that I have it even puts down
the school board members in their
history anybody receives money is listed
foreign
town does it as well
um has the positions and everything but
the PDF is available on the website so
you can access it there so I'm wondering
if other accounts also put that book on
the websites and that way the
information would be accessible
further discussion represent Lucas
um Charles who put it up as a PDF or in
whatever form electronically are already
doing it that's great so we passed this
and they'll say check already done they
don't we're not asking any more work or
anything from them I think it's the
towns that aren't doing it it's for the
citizens who want to have that
information and don't have it and so I
think that's what this is directed at
not the towns who are doing it they're
already doing it so great
is this a local control issue or is this
a state issue
how many how many districts in the state
are doing this already
those are questions which I don't have
the answers to
but
if in fact it's not happening in a
school district why then aren't they
doing that has somebody requested it to
be done or not
um I don't have that answer either
so are we making legislation here for
what purpose
and how do we enforce it
those are the questions I have
so is there any further discussion
okay we have a motion on the floor Madam
clerk would you please read the motion
it's OTP
yes
OTP so TP okay
it's OTP uh relative to school district
information on Personnel salaries
sorry I misplaced the sheet so that's
why I was
the one that made the motion uh
represent cordelli made the motion
and who seconded it and representative
my stuff here so
Vice chairman cordelli yes
representative blackis yes
representative Ford
yes representative Belcher yes
representative Mater yes representative
McDonnell yes representative Noble yes
representative paternal
yes representative courtiello yes
representative Miler no representative
Cornell no representative Tanner no
Representative luno no
representative Ellison no representative
Woodcock no representative Morton no
representative Balboni no representative
Cascade and no representative Damon no
chairman Lads yes
10 years 10 days
I'll move itl
and
discussion from the maker the motion
representative Luna thank you very much
Mr chair my concern is that the um you
know unlike the uh the voluntary uh uh
or or local control uh policy for uh for
publishing positions and uh and annual
or hourly salaries or compensation
um that uh that this um
policy in 553 is so rigid that uh that
it would not give a school district any
discretion but to disclose the names of
um of of parents or Guardians who may be
compensated for transporting their their
student uh with an IEP to and out of
District placement and um and oftentimes
these students are are
being receiving specialized services at
um in some cases I know because we've
heard this in committee at uh at six
figure costs to the community and
um and I know that when I was on both
the school board and the budget
committee that uh that we um we would
redact information that was shared with
the budget committee if a student's
identity was going to be be exposed to
that and I'm just afraid that 553 would
not provide any discretion question for
a school district to be able to uh to
protect
um uh you know a vulnerable student's
identity and um and I just think this is
this is a terribly broad policy that
deserves to be itl'd represent cordelli
thank you
um there's nothing in here about
requiring
um the uh the purpose of the payment I
think Transportation
would be simple enough in cases like
that and I think that districts would
certainly respect
confidentiality I know of a parent who
is
transporting under contract with the
district their child for uh dyslexia
instruction
um and I would think that districts
would be wise enough not to say that
they're transporting ex person is
transporting for IEP
Transportation or for other types of
transportation that might you know
reveal confidentiality
so I don't see that as an issue really
further discussion representative yeah
sure thank you very much Mr chair and
and thank you um representative cordelli
for suggesting that but I'm just not uh
I I don't see it in the in the in in the
language here in 553 that would give a
school district any discretion other
than to publish on each school or the
district website a complete list of all
position names and their annual or
hourly salaries and um and I think you
know to the extent that um that that the
Department of Education or maybe uh
somebody that feels that a school
district is not uh complying with the
law If This Were to become law to the uh
to the the fullest extent that um that
this discretion that that school boards
have right now when they when they go
ahead and and print lists like the uh
like what is in the Haverhill Town
report that uh that they'll have no
choice but to disclose the names of
parents who are transporting their child
um as a result of an IEP and in a small
town as representative Damon was
suggesting people put two and two
together and uh know what's going on
Representative cordelli no thank you
there's nothing in here about a
requirement to post individual names
just positions
represent Damon
in small towns where you only have one
person in the position
you may be listing it only as a position
but it is obviously that person
representative
Transportation provider is a position
name it doesn't need any more than that
further discussion
representative Tanner
yes in in reading the bill it says
position names and their annual or
hourly salary
um
that doesn't mean it's I mean it doesn't
it doesn't save positions it says
position names
so
it's in
further discussion
Adam Clerk
we have a motion on the table the motion
is the itl
uh HB 553 a relative School District
information on Personnel salaries
Vice chairman cordelli
no
Representative leckis no representative
Ford
no representative Belcher no
Representative notter no representative
McDonald no representative Noble no
Representative no Representative no
representative Miler yes representative
Cornell yes representative Tanner yes
representative Luna yes
representative Ellison yes
representative Woodcock yes
representative Morton yes representative
Balboni yes representative cascadden yes
representative Damon yes
chairman Ladd no
10 years 10 days
for the motions
I like to make a motion to retain
okay
um the reason why I feel that I would
like to either see it retained or uh
this is being done and I believe that uh
I don't know if it's being done in all
towns but our cities but they have the
capability to do that and they don't
have any anything saying they shouldn't
um so
I I believe we're stepping the turf of
local control
and of a school board
um or a municipal form of government a
select border or a city council
I believe that the this decision is a
local decision if somebody doesn't like
what's going on the local level then
they have to communicate it there I've
not seen enough information to convince
me that this is a Statewide issue
so that's why I present the motion to
retain one second
who seconded represent woodcock
further discussion can we uh do a hand
vote
per routine you can do that
yeah I think we're going to get a I
think that you know I've been done
retain by showing of hands before uh
seeing it it doesn't go anywhere
other than for us
so
any further discussion
okay Madam clerk would you ask for the
hand vote
hey how do I do that yes
both hands those that are in favor of
retention
those who are in favor of retention okay
okay and then I count
one two three four
five
seven eight nine ten eleven
did I do it yeah everybody this is new
okay
so the bill has retained
in committee
all right the next one down is the last
one for today 628 requiring certain
non-public schools or education service
providers that accept public funds to
perform background checks on all
employees and volunteers
representative
did you have a motion here
or I let's see I who
I would like to move itl second
okay we have a motion made by represent
Lucas itl
who seconded that on that side
representative McDonald
reps and luck is do you want to speak to
your motion
sure
okay I had to find my bill I was still
on the last one
um
the problem with this it talks about for
one thing
um volunteers and what exactly does that
entail
but the other thing is if you read this
what we're going to do there's two two
big issues to me we're going to be
background checking parents
because there are a lot of co-ops where
the parents all get together and the
kids get together and a parent will
teach on something that's their
specialty perhaps it's something that
they do for a living and another parent
will teach on their specialty so now
we're going to be background checking
parents and I know there is a lot of
um objections amongst the community
about background checking parents but
the other part of that is I'm not sure
we have yet figured out how we're doing
all of these background checks and the
people who come in as volunteers to
prevent to present a program for one
time or two times
do we get background checks and who does
the background checks and if it's not an
organized actual official school but
just a co-op
but some of those kids might be
receiving money for one thing or another
then that counts by this bill but the
question is
um who does the background check where
does it go we've heard a lot of issues
with the uh
the department of safety explaining how
they can't just give that information
out to anybody it has to go to an
official at a school or School depart
we're still working on how to do that so
I don't see how this can even be done
it's got way too many flaws thank you
further discussion
represent Myler
this is an important bill
um
as service providers begin to expand
one of the responsibilities this
committee has
is to ensure the safety of kids
and right now
perhaps you have it I haven't seen it in
this committee yet I have no idea what
the volume of service providers is I
don't know who they are
where they are what they do
and it would seem to me that this this
bill provides some sense of uh Safe
Harbor
to look at the issue
of where our service providers are and
volunteers so there is a definition of
volunteer in in the law right now so
we're not talking about somebody who
comes in from a volunteer standpoint
somebody who comes in and is there for a
single shot we used in our as we
said if Yo-Yo Ma comes in and wants to
do an instruction uh for a day he's not
going to have to have a a criminal
records check
so the law already defines what a
volunteer is
and so I I just think that this bill as
again going back to some of the other
stuff we've had on the issue of school
choice if we're going to move in this
direction there ought to be some sense
of understanding from a from a legal
standpoint of making sure our kids are
safe now I understand the argument I
truly understand the argument that well
if you've got parents there they
basically monitor themselves I
understand that but you know if you're
going to have uh kids go over to the uh
um the uh Southeast soccer program for
example and as part of the CFE EFA
program we don't know what's going on
there we don't know who those coaches
are we don't know what their background
is and yet we're going to have our kids
go there it would seem to me that that
it's responsibility of this committee to
begin to look at that and all this bill
is trying to do is to provide some sense
of of understanding of what that means
anybody else that's in school goes to
through a background check at some point
in time
and so I would just I would just hope
people would begin to look at the need
for at least to begin to look at this
thing as the volume of service providers
increase thank you Mr chairman thank you
representative cascadden
thank you just want to reference the 189
13 on um that's already on the books
there is a section that addresses
um just take a minute to read a few
lines a non-public school may elect to
require a criminal history records check
on selected applicants for employment or
selected volunteers and a non-public
school that elects to conduct a criminal
history records check she'll comply with
the procedures and requirements set
forth in the sections so it's selected
volunteers and selected applicants now
when you look at the EFA use of EFA
funds
there are several driving schools that
are on that list that someone could use
their EFA funds for driver's ed
so you could potentially have students
who are alone with a driver
they should have a criminal background
check
um
Arts music ballet
um ticondo or you know any martial arts
if there's an individual
adult in a student or two students they
should have criminal background check
I don't think the intent is that the
parent who's homeschooling needs a
criminal check that's
that's not the issue here
it's making sure
that it raises the bar on the law that's
already on the books that say they may
do it
instead of now saying we require to do
it
because
we want the safety of the kids in
whatever scenario they are alone with an
adult or with any adult working with
kids in some capacity so it is selected
volunteers selected applicants
I mean EFA whoever oversees that could
go through their vendor list and
determine how are they providing
education to students and determine
whether it's feasible for a background
check or not so that's what this law
does
further discussion representative lecus
I'm not sure how they're determining
whether it's feasible for a background
check given that this says that they
have to have one
um I also don't understand how having
one background check makes any kid safer
given that as you said the public
schools have to and I can tell you that
my daughter's best friend was pregnant
from uh one of the teachers in the
school and so I don't I think background
checks make you feel good I don't think
it actually does anything and so far you
haven't explained to me however much we
want and I agree I would like to know
whether somebody is an issue or not
before I let my kids go there but I want
to know how you're going to if you're
say a co-op now Co-op has to provide
um money for a space to meet or whatever
and so students get charged for that
students may use their EFA money to pay
for that facility
and it may just be parents teaching
other kid you know teaching each other's
kids
how they are not a school how are they
going to get the background checks done
I mean it's nice to say oh you have to
do it but how are you going to do it
that's my question I I don't see this as
being feasible now eventually we're
talking about the Department of
Education being able you know have a
depository and any of these people could
do a background check one time and it
would be on record and then people could
check but we're not there yet so how can
we pass this law
when we don't even have a way of
implementing it yet thank you
further discussion representative Tanner
then represented cascadden
thank you I guess uh just to address a
couple of issues one about the
volunteers that school districts
actually or can make up the what they
consider designated volunteers and the
vast majority of them that if a
volunteer comes in on a one-time basis
or if a volunteer is in a situation
comes into my classroom I'm in the
classroom it's actually supervised what
they have volunteers do background
checks is when they're one-on-one or one
on Two And they come on a regular basis
so there's the designated volunteers as
representative cascadden said in 189 13
has already been talked about camps
athletic camps in the summer any kind of
camps um have to do these background
checks and we actually had someone come
and testify that she worked in a co-op
but she also got background checks for
Girl Scouts background checks when she
was with a fishing game
Rod and Gun Club did work so there are
people doing background checks all over
the place and we have it now for
substitutes where a substitute can get
background checks that apply in
different places we have it for
transportation people what we're really
doing is representative Miler said is
trying to make kids safe now there's no
100 guarantee we know what happens in
schools we know what happens in churches
we know what happens in with parents
that there's incest we know things
happen but what we're trying to do is
we're trying to make things as safe as
we possibly can and one of the things
that we've as a society said that helps
us see if somebody is safe is to do a
background check and the background
check that schools have or people that
work with children is much different
than the person that goes in and gets a
background check to work at Walmart
they're concerned with robbery or murder
or arson
the school checks the checks with
working with children extend further and
deal with trafficking child trafficking
child pornography different issues like
that that are specific that would
endanger children so that's what this
bill is meant to do
and I really
think that it's worth consideration and
it is feasible we know we can do it so
that's that's my response to some of the
questions represent cascadden just
wanted to add that there is a system
from my experience
um with people outside of school
district who need criminal background
check and that's through the state
police barracks within your region
so I don't know if that's the case all
over the state but
F Troop into a mountain we'll do
background checks for whatever you need
it for so just the service is there
represent McDonald thank you Mr chair
I'd just like to remind the committee of
the extensive testimony we had in
opposition to this bill overwhelmingly
the testifiers that took time out of
their day to speak to us oppose this
bill I have one quoted as saying that
it's a baseless Inquisition on
homeschool families and knowing that it
is almost discriminatory against a
certain class of parents that's looking
for a problem what a problem may or may
not exist I just don't know why we would
support something like that
further discovers in Belcher thank you
Mr chair I I would like to highlight
that safety is obviously the important
issue but there is a line that you cross
when you go from safety to safety ism
and when you start dictating to parents
who needs to get a background check when
they're when they're getting together in
their little homeschool pods and this
that and the other this that's nothing
but government overreach parents have
the ability to make these decisions on
their own without any sort of
interference from us or anyone else
discussion represent cordelli
thank you Mr chair
a number of things
first
tax credit scholarships efas
money is going to
families and they are making individual
private choices let me quote former
Supreme Court Justice for New Hampshire
Charles Douglas
the court Drew consistent distinctions
between government programs that provide
Aid directly to religious schools and
programs of true private choice in which
the government Aid reaches religious
schools only by the result of genuine
and independent choices of private
individuals
this is getting into the lives of
private individuals
uh two
um
this bill references
um continually
um 189 was it 13 a right
that statute
references that these background checks
are to go to school Personnel SAU School
District personnel
so are we saying that background checks
of a volunteer or a Home School
parent support person who comes in to
help The Homeschool parent they have to
send the background check they have to
get a background check and send a
background check to the local school
what are we saying it's not
the bill is is a fraud from a whole
number of uh perspectives
representative cascadden obviously
disagree when you look at the service
provider list I'm not talking about
putting parents through a criminal
background check talking about the
providers
that are giving some sort of
lesson or education
to a child whether they're a homeschool
child or not it's to me is irrelevant
it's the service provider
that people are using efas for
if they are ever in a small group with a
kid so the onus is not on the parent to
get the background check but as a parent
if I'm homeschooling and I want my child
to go to McIntyre Ski area for a private
ski lesson and I pay for it with the
efas I'd want that instructed to have a
criminal background check because I
wouldn't trust anybody to be with my
child so it's more on the service
provider same when I go back to the
driving school do you want your teenage
daughter to get into a driving school
situation not knowing any background on
that driver
absolutely not nobody would want that
but that's the intent here for those
vendors
to have criminal background checks so
that they can advertise that they are
safe they're on a service provider list
we don't know if they're ex-felons or
not
I mean what's the vehicle to do that so
that's what this Bell would do in my
opinion representative cordelli
thank you and uh I agree with one aspect
of what you said uh that parent who
takes their child to a ski area for ski
instruction it's up to them whether they
have this uh ski instructor get a pro
get a background check or not it's not
my responsibility as an education
Committee Member to do it or the state
responsibility to do which the parents
responsibility to do it if they want and
let me just quote from the letter that
we got from the Catholic Church also
um
that
that is why the fingerprint based checks
for the Diocese of Manchester schools
are carried out by the division of State
Police pursuant to the federal Adam
Walsh act specifically the school SAFE
Act 34 USC 2962.
so they're doing checks on their
personnel
further discussion from the committee
that's good representative
I wonder if all those McIntyre people do
have checks because you brought it up
but I realized that our school Ski Club
goes
I mean our school Ski Club goes to
Mcintyre and and so the question is are
they are are they not I have no idea but
I don't think I partic I I was a
chaperone and anyway
for further discussion yes yes
so I'm a newbie here thank you very much
for letting me speak I just have a
question for clarification
current School Personnel are subject to
background checks and this would
do background checks on anyone related
to a school district and that includes
people who would be
receiving any kind of EFA
money
yes
so the question is
we just
voted down
for are in debate about whether or not
to make everybody's salary a
transparency issue wouldn't this fall
under that same kind of thing like
transparency issues
if we're doing background checks at the
school level shouldn't anyone who
receives the fa funds do background
checks as well
person like us
at the school level
it's done by the school but if there's
not a school who's going to do the
background check
and and we did have the department of
safety here explaining who who can do
those and they did not find a way yet
for the random parent to do it
for other random parents who gets the
who and according to this it would be
the school what school
which school if you have parents getting
together from five different towns
who's doing the background check who's
getting the background check they're not
employees of the school how is the
school even going to get it I mean
that's it's it's a nice idea but we
don't have anything in place for those
fingerprint checks to actually be done
yes you can do a New Hampshire one but
that's not going to be that full level
one that they're talking about here I
don't see how you can even
pass this when we don't have the
mechanism in place to do it yet
further discussion representative miler
thank you Mr chair I'd like to inform
the committee that should this itl
motion fail uh we will be putting
forward a retained motion from this
for the committee to consider
further discussion from the committee
just something for clarification
purposes as a superintendent when you go
through and you're doing these checks or
your designation this is not information
for the public
this is all kept close to the chest
and for a number of reasons
okay further discussion
okay Madam Clerk
motion is itl on 628
background checks on all employees and
volunteers
Vice chairman cordelli yes
representative blackis
yes representative Ford
yes representative Belcher yes
representative
sorry
representative McDonald yes
representative Noble yes representative
paternal yes representative courtiello
yes representative Miler no
representative Cornell
representative Tanner no
Representative luno no
representative Ellison no representative
Woodcock no representative Mark Morton
no representative Balboni no
Representative cascadin no
representative Damon no
chairman that
yeah no
no
excuse yeah yes yes he just said no to
me
yes
I'm saying yes for the itl okay so
representative let's go back
representative Damon
the Motions actually the motion is itl
yes
representative Damon
which was Ito you had already said nay
but it sounded yeah so reminds me yes
okay
chairman Ladd yes
10 years 10 days
Mr chair
I'd like to make a motion to retain
for a second
okay we have motion made by represent
Tanner and second by uh representative
miler
discussion representative Tanner
um I think this uh is a safety bill and
I think um some of the questions can be
answered and and if amendments need to
be made they could be made to this bill
but I I really think that student safety
is uh key here
further discussion
I think we've had enough conversation I
do too it's lunch time
any further discussion we have a motion
to retain on 6 28
Madam clerk Vice chairman cordelli yes
Representative blackis no
representative for
no
representative Belcher no representative
nodder yes
representative McDonald no
Hold Us
representative Noble no
Representative pedernal no
Representative courtiello no
representative Miler yes
representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner
representative blue now representative
Ellison yes representative Woodcock yes
representative Morton yes representative
Balboni
representative
representative Damon yes
chairman Ladd yes
13 years seven Nays
okay the bill is retained
with that we're down at the bottom of
the docket for today I would like to
remind people that made these motions
that we need to get the committee
reports or the minority majority report
completed today please so we can get
this to
our Administrative Assistant if you're
not sure whether you made a motion or
not check in over here before you head
out of the out of the door here anything
else for the committee at this time
not seeing thank you very much and have
a good afternoon
um okay we uh
you have a copy of that list and I I
will I'll get copies made
um
we're trying to get them today if we can
probably
yeah tonight's fine too yeah yeah I know
I'll get them now
I wanted this chicken